hey youtubers is charlie so since there
have been so many questions about what
kind of videos I'm going to be doing and
what's going to be happening this fall I
wanted to do like a master trailer video
just explaining everything this is going
to cover everything between September
right now in December including shows
movies even the video game channel I
know some of you might know about my not
so secret video game channel Charlie's
dreams seriously there's so much awesome
stuff coming you guys have no idea how
excited I am if you're fighting me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get all my stuff my name is Charlie and
I like fiction there's also some really
important business that I have woefully
neglected we're almost at 400,000
subscribers here and first of all just
thank you for being amazing that just
blows my mind but we need to think of a
name for ourselves right now I'm
thinking the Legion sounds really nice
but while I explain what my video plan
is start thinking about names okay so
important stuff starting with the
schedule I'm just going to do TV shows
first and i'm going to do these by day
of the week starting with monday so
mondays are going to be Gotham and Star
Wars rebels Gotham is the batman prequel
show on Fox it starts sep tember 22nd at
eight pm eastern time all the time slots
I'm gonna mention will be in eastern
time so just adjust based on which time
zone you live in as you may have seen
it's going to be told from the
perspective of Detective Gordon played
by Ben McKenzie the number one reason
why you need to watch this show is
because it's going to feature almost
every Batman villain you could think of
for example Hugo Strange and Arkham
Asylum are going to be heavily featured
it's a prequel for Batman and it's a
prequel for Arkham Asylum this also
going to be this cool running gag where
they feature a new comedian in the main
villains comedy club each week it's just
a teaser for who they might end up
casting as the Joker but even the super
haters and the blogosphere that saw the
first episode we're really blown away
totally it's going to feel a lot more
like a really dark cop drama with
superheroes in it Donal Logue who's
playing Bullock is gonna be so much fun
to watch so next up is Star Wars rebels
because disney bought lucasfilm it's
going to air on disney XD it starts
october 13th at 9pm so see things are
already working out you can watch Gotham
first and then rebels right after the
number one reason why you should watch
rebels is because right now is the
beginning of this unprecedented thing in
the Star Wars universe
we're all the movies the TV shows the
novels and the comics exist in a shared
universe Star Wars underneath Disney's
watchful eye of course is going to do
the same thing that Marvel's doing where
the TV shows affect what's happening in
the movies and vice versa since rebels
is a prequel show about the time between
episode 3 in episode 4 it'll give a lot
of background about what's going on when
episode seven picks up they are making a
few slight modifications to the movie
canon like the original movie canon but
rebels will explain all that so moving
on to Tuesday's now Tuesday's will be
agents of shield season two the flash
season one and supernatural season 10
shield and supernatural are going to air
at the same time so they'll be a bit of
a conflict but I'll explain how i'm
gonna fix that problem the first one to
premiere though will be agents of shield
that's coming September 23rd at nine
p.m. on ABC they already confirmed that
Hayley Atwell will be in the first
episode as her agent Carter character
probably in a flashback but the number
one reason why you should watch shield
season two is because all the new Marvel
characters that are rolling out and it's
going to be overlapping with Avengers
age of Ultron next up is the flash with
Grant Gustin that premieres October 7th
at a p.m. on the CW I've already been
doing a ton of bonus videos for this but
the number one reason why you need to
watch it is because is also the
beginning of this unprecedented time in
DC Comics television where characters
from each of the four shows get to
overlap that's right there's four DC
Comics TV shows on air at the same time
flash already has this huge list of
comic book characters they've cast
including firestorm and a bunch of
people from prison break that are
playing the roads and moving on to
supernatural season 10 it's premiering
right after that first episode of the
flash at 9pm also on the CW it overlaps
with agents of shield they air at the
same time so what I'm probably going to
do is i'll still post a video for the
premiere but i might just do
supernatural videos in some other way
like as a blog post or something on
tumblr for those of you that don't know
I do have a website called emergency
awesome calm I just haven't posted
anything there in a year so i might
start using that again I need to make it
look a little bit more shiny so there's
some work I have to do before I start
posting there again but moving on to
Wednesday's this is basically going to
be the arrow day that premieres the same
week as the flash on october eight at
eight
p.m. on the CW I did videos for all of
season 2 and everyone really loved it so
if you're new to the show and you have
not been watching it the number one
reason you need to is because they're
basically doing justice league on TV
every single week that's right even just
between the flash and arrow they're
basically doing a one-hour justice
league episode every single week way
before the movies ever get there I don't
have any TV shows that I'm planning on
making videos for on Thursday so that's
basically going to be like my ketchup
day for other bonus videos or other fun
stuff but friday will be the new
Constantine show that's the fourth DC
Comics TV show it's starting october
24th at 10pm on NBC the number one
reason why you need to watch this is the
same reason as air on the flash it's
going to heavily feature characters from
the comic books and we'll fill that
magic gap in the DC Universe in terms of
movies and TV right now magic doesn't
exist on arrow the flash or in the
movies so Constantine is kind of like
the magic based comic book show they
even just cast the spectre I haven't
done a lot of bonus videos for this yet
but I will start in the next week I got
to see that first episode at comic-con
so I'll probably do a non-spoilery
review just because most people probably
haven't seen it then moving on to
Saturday's obviously everyone knows
about Doctor Who series 8 that's
continuing through november eight on BBC
america or BBC in the UK depending on
where you live new episodes air in the
UK at seven-thirty gmt + 9 p.m. on BBC
america if you're not watching doctor
who yet episodes are basically made to
stand on their own so you don't have to
worry about having not watched all of
Doctor Who I feel like a lot of people
get put off just because of the sheer
quantity of Doctor Who out there they
just feel like it's too much to handle
but I do a ton of bonus videos for it
every week so this should help get you
up to speed I'll say of all the science
fiction shows I do this is my favorite I
do consider the comic book genre to be
different so I'm not lumping all that in
together moving on to Sunday's Walking
Dead Season 5 is coming back that starts
October twelfth at 9pm on AMC I did
videos for all season four and everyone
had a lot of fun so it's going to be the
same drill as last year I'll say the
number one reason you need to watch this
is machine gun Rick is gonna [ __ ] [ __ ]
up I know I don't swear a lot but
walking dead is going to get really
hardcore this season i'll so totally be
doing bonus videos for Game of Thrones
and legend of korra and some of the
other things i do i just might shuffle
of the days that I post those videos if
I do end up moving things around I'll
just make announcements about when stuff
is happening in those bonus videos
whenever I post them so if you want to
know when new Game of Thrones videos
posts just watch my game of Thrones
videos and same thing for Korra so on to
movies now I know a lot of you have been
requesting a lot of extra movie videos
and yes I am planning on doing a bunch
more of this fall obviously I'll be
doing all the Marvel DC star wars stuff
that I've been doing but here's a list
of other stuff that I'm planning on
doing that's coming soon so this month
there's Maze Runner and boxtrolls
remember that starts brand from Game of
Thrones in October there's dracula
untold starring luke evans and then
there's the new Daniel Radcliffe movie
horns then in November there's a whole
bunch of stuff there's the new
Christopher Nolan movie interstellar big
hero 6 hunger games mockingjay in the
new Benedict Cumberbatch movie imitation
game that's about charles babbage
december is the last Hobbit movie ever
Battle of the five armies so make sure
you go see that they're probably not
going to be making any more talking
movies Peter Jackson did say comic-con
he was totally down for it if new line
wanted to squeeze more material out of
it but moving on to video games I know a
lot of you have requested more video
game stuff now that I've officially
moved into my new apartment I will start
doing more stuff on my video game
channel for instance you know obviously
everyone's talking about destiny right
now my copies on xbox one but mostly
most of the games that i'll be doing
will be on steam just because it's much
more convenient for streaming if you
haven't seen them yet my video game
channel is called Charlie's dreams it's
like my bonus channel i also have a
twitch channel called emergency awesome
so tons of amazing stuff coming I
totally would not spend all this time
making videos for it if I didn't think
was going to be awesome so extra links
for my other channels and all those
stuff in the description just to give
you an idea for when videos are going to
post for all these things generally
videos for episodes of TV will post with
it about three hours of them airing on
TV but for example on mondays and
tuesdays when I have two shows I'll do
like the first show that night and then
the next one the morning after I can
really only make about two videos a day
but basically things will post in the
order that they aired during the week I
will be live tweeting as much as
possible so you can follow me there my
twitter handle is at
some emergency but everywhere else like
Facebook Instagram I'm emergency awesome
again links for all that stuff in the
description so i hope they just gives
you an idea for what I'm planning for
the fall I will do another video like
this like after everything goes on break
for the winter like november december
but if there's anything that you have
questions about that you didn't see me
talk about in the video just let me know
in the comments so in the meantime click
here to start getting ready for arrow in
the flash and click here to start
getting ready for agents of shield and
all the Marvel's stuff this fall thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
guys tonight high fives